this is a really weird one the
developers of the upcoming FPS the
finals which looks tons of fun I did
play the beta and it is a wild ride is
apparently using AI instead of real
voice actors because it takes just a
matter of hours rather than months they
said that all of their voice acting is
AI except for things like grunts so
basically exerion everything else is AI
they said the reason that we went this
route is that AI textas speech is
finally extremely powerful it gets us
far enough in terms of quality and
allows us to be extremely reactive to
new ideas if a game designer comes with
a new idea for a game mode we can have
that voice over representing that in
just a matter of hours instead of months
voice actors are very confused by this
though One Voice act to Giani matri
Grano said we are constantly banging out
Rush order sessions for like within a
day or two when you need more you can
book another session we actually make it
very easy and if you'd like to hear how
some of it sounds now the king fish the
jet Setters and finally the powerhouses
and they are off and they are off cash
the team that tucks away enough money
first triumphs